hier muss das haupt wiesen durch meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren mord vorstellung mein
auge hat kein bisschen
und ich wollte euch heute die von
charlotte vorstellen die ein boom update
bekommen hat es ist aber auch schon ein
bisschen länger her dass wir nun einmal
dazu erwähnen weil das bassum eigentlich
dass alle cool sein ganzes habe ich doch
zudem bekomme ich erst am ende
wir fangen erst mal mit dem normalen
sachen also es werden möbel hinzugefügt
es ja furniture besetzt er geht erst mal
hier zu sein ich habe jetzt ein kleines
haus gebaut ich kann nicht bauen und das
einzig wichtige an diesem haus ist das
beispielsweise mit sogar dienen voll ist
mit tischen follis tätig mit bei netbook
von acer zwar kein weihnachten aber hey
ich hab ihn trotzdem eingestellt
mit tischen mit alle möglichen sachen
ich würde sagen wir fangen eigentlich
erstmal wir können eigentlich drin
anfang und zwar haben wir hier erst mal
die sofas erstmal im inventar sehen wir
hier müsste crayfish freuen
da können wir jedes ist eine seite
weiter lesen diese normalen sachen und
ihr zustand ist mit fördert und dann
sehen wir hier das hier ganz ganz viel
schaden zugefügt werden beispielsweise
beheimaten couch und stereotyp präsent
und ganz ganz viele andere sachen
hinzugefügt werden dass das tier
hinzugefügt wird ist beispielsweise
setzt die couch mit der firma ganz kurz
anfang der verschiedene couches das
heißt man verschiedene farben und wir
können die einfach wenn wir einen
möbelteile hinsetzen wollte einfach nur
herumstehen oder halt dann in rotbraun
letztlich habe ich sicher rasch einsatz
in verschiedenen farben und wenn man die
halter nebeneinander setzt verbinden die
sich einige erst mal und wenn man eine
kurve baute mit eine kurve baut wenn man
so um die ecke baut dann verbinden die
sich auch um die ecke also das ist
relativ cool und auch wenn er neben
beispielsweise sogar steht wie seine
camping oder so dann ist das nicht
unbedingt dass diese lehne dann eben
wieder zwischen backt oder so sondern
dass dieser kevin wirklich daneben steht
und wir gesehen dass wir können uns wird
richtig da drauf sitzen und jetzt die
negativen dinge wohl fühlen wir könnten
uns nicht bewegen also ich drücke gerade
die tasten das funktioniert nicht
ich muss hier wenn schon shift drücken
und dann bin ich von diesen ganzen
dingen wieder los das heißt ich bin nie
wieder runter gegangen
und das ist erst mal zu diesem couches
und dann kommen wir nämlich oft schon
hier zu den sachen die ich schon gezeigt
und zwar kabinett so was wie einfach so
ein kleiner kaputt also unseren
kleiderschrank den man irgendwo
hinstellen kann dann können wir auch
wieder oben an bringt meiner küche oder
so und es ist einfach wie kisten quasi
seine storage place also wir können die
sache rein stellen die werke zweier
bilder wie beispielsweise irgendwie eine
schale mit essen oder so weil die halt
eigentlich für die küche zu gebrauchen
sind die pakistaner rein es ist quasi
wie eine kiste und das sind diese
kabinetts dann haben wir die tische
davon gibt es zwei stück einmal in stein
als don coffee table und wurden coffee
table also
kaffeekränzchen tische ich glaube man
kann auch nix drauf stellen also wenn
ich das richtige mache dann geht da noch
höher
oder wenn ich da irgendwie einen flower
pop wer interessant das habe ich noch
gar nicht getestet weil ich auf die idee
noch gar nicht gekommen aber nie wir
sehen schon da kann man nix drauf dem
muss man dann eben stellen dass wir
eventuell auf cool dass es dazu kommt
dass man da auch so sachen drauf stellen
kann ich bin hier immer noch befürworter
der getränke in minecraft das war
richtig cool aber das ist auf jeden fall
diese kritische die wir hier hingestellt
haben die habe ich auch hier nochmal in
einer größeren form und zwar gibt es da
eine einmal den sound table und den
studios in den strand genommen den boden
table und genau 30 minuten es down cher
und modenschauen genau die gleiche
funktion da kann man es auch drauf
setzen dann sitzen wir hier an den
tischen das passt doch alles mit den
proportionen also wir sitzen hier
wirklich mit den füßen und am tisch so
wie sich das gehört wie das schiff
zurück und wir sind von dem ding runter
das geht natürlich bei den anderen
stören da kann man ja mal drauf setzen
so danzig jetzt hat nur wieder auf dem
tisch das ist ein bisschen profi kann
dort rausspringen die auch auf die
stühle und auf dem tisch das macht man
es eigentlich nicht aber man kann zum
beispiel nicht auf die couch
einfach so sich einfach mal
beispielsweise ihnen die auf die leine
setzen oder so dass wir eventuell noch
ganz gut wenn man sich da irgendwie
anlegen könnt oder irgendwie sowas
google dürfe und ja also das ist mal zu
diesem diesen interieur zu dieser
einrichtung
dann gibt es hier noch diesen diesem
weihnachtsbaum ich habe schon am anfang
gesagt es ist zwar kein weihnachten aber
ich habe den mann trotz mehrerer
eingepackt da liegen geschenke darunter
da können wir uns einfach mal kurz in
den game zu null bewegen und
beispielsweise mal irgendwie das ding
zum beispiel abbauen und dann sehen wir
wie kriegen quasi dieses geräusch als
wenn wir irgendwie wird verzaubert
hätten oder so und da steht am merry
christmas von korn crafter weil ich das
ganze verpackt habe und zum beispiel in
dem geschenk war gerade ein weiteres
geschenk das ist jetzt endlich der
sondern ein kleiner scherz
ihr könnt es mit dem anderen ding machen
da ist zum beispiel ein porzellan
sternchen dann drin
und wie das ganze funktioniert ist
einfach wir haben dieses empty präsent
können richtig drauf machen irgendwo hin
also nicht auf dem blog blog weil dann
steht juni tickets ein
bevor ihr camp lake city also irgendwo
in die luft der packende spots land
kennt ihn rein machen
dann können wir das hier hinstellen so
könnte es wir abbauen und dann steht da
merry christmas von kraft an und bekomme
ich beispielsweise porzellan sternchen
also sehr cool
ja ich weiß ganze mal weg ich gebe auch
wieder den gamern 1 und zwar gibt es
noch drei sachen die ich euch hier im
raum zeigen möchte und zwar einerseits
diese lampen die kommen jetzt mal so
komplett ausmachen also die brauchen
keine redstone quelle oder irgendwie
hier verbarg sich das gerade mit diesem
blöden weihnachtsbaum links stellt man
ganz gezeigt und die können wir dann
auch wieder anmachen und ihr seht schon
dass das licht an so ein bisschen besser
wird das sehen wir auch gleich schon
wenn wir hier zum beispiel haben wir
blind und körper ins also vorhänge und
diese rollladen und da wird es hier drin
echt dunkler und wenn wir das
theoretisch gleich mal alles zu bauen
drucken sie grad ein bisschen es ist
immer noch diese dieser 1.8 dingsbums
und jetzt ist hier wirklich alles dunkel
also die sachen verschließen quasi
wirklich alles so unumgänglich mit licht
wir können sie wieder das licht anmachen
damit ihr seht dass diese teile ich
schon ein bisschen licht kreieren und
ich lasse jetzt einfach mal alle an und
baut das thema wieder offen und wir
sehen von außen vor den fenstern von
außen sieht nicht so gut aus aber man
kann es gleich natürlich auch noch von
außen machen dass man da so clients
verhängt und das ganze ist auf jeden
fall relativ cool
dann gehen wir jetzt mal ein stück nach
draußen und zwar sehen wir hier schon
der sound den finden wir hier das ist
was ganz normal ist also ein ganz
normaler weg da kommen wir jetzt nicht
irgendwie höher oder so können da
einfach überlaufen et cetera pp und
einfach so eine kleine verschönerung
auch das weitere verschönerungen sind
zum beispiel dieser weit fans da ist wie
sonst kann man nicht drüber springen und
ich hab's gern doppelt sich also hier
sind noch mal auch hedge da kann ich
auch nicht drüber springen als wenn ich
dagegen sprintet dann ist es quasi wie
ein zaun
den habe ich hier einfach rum umgebaut
genauso wie den fans dann habe ich mir
gedacht nämlich noch mal andere sachen
und zwar gibt es auch noch den spurs
hedgefonds normal hecke dann gibt es
hier noch dieses sports und halt dieses
jungle also es gibt lange moment jungle
und auch also diese vier sorten halt
gibt es an ließ die man hier als hecken
nutzen kann die kamera auch noch ein
stückchen höher bauen beispielsweise das
auch mal ganz kurz ist quasi wie ganz
normale lief nur man kann dort nicht
drüber springen und die sind ein
bisschen kleiner also ein bisschen
schmaler gehalten
und da kommen jetzt schon zur letzten
sache und zwar also zur letzten sache
von diesem ding was ich euch jetzt hier
zeigen wollte
und zwar dem ende auf dem package und
dem mailbox und zwar können wir erst mal
richtig drauf machen als nationales fach
weil es meine mailbox ist dann ist die
mailbox von irgendwem anders gewesen
wäre dann hätte ich ja nicht richtig
drauf machen können aber durch öffnen
können dafür gibt es dann den hammer das
kann zum beispiel atmen
der kann dann richtig machen also schiff
trächtigen magica mailbox ist noch an
mark bell box ist lockt also man kann
dabei an noch jeder darauf zugreifen und
bei anlockt
doch jeder und bei lok nur ich
so wir haben jetzt hier beispielsweise
nennt will ob wenn ich auf dem boden
clique oder auch mit dem package und
funktioniert das ganze nicht antreten
und ist diese meldungen der wiederkommen
wir können entweder in die luft machen
beispielsweise in grasberg rhein und
sieg wäre das dann steht da male hier
mail vom contractor gleichen package
pac-man graz ein sieg wäre das und dann
steht da
ebenfalls in form konkreter vancouver ab
ecke stehen würde
jetzt kann ich hier mit 30 zweimal auch
darauf zugreifen ich kann mir das schiff
technik drücken und zac karte sind
creative das natürlich klar weil es an
zu sparen könnte mit brief mit maximal 1
kontrast
also das ist ein bisschen blöd welches
karte meinen eigenen briefkasten getan
habe aber er soll einfach sein sonst
wenn ich das zum beispiel jetzt für
komme in seinem haus packen würde
ständig you bekomme und dann wird komme
hier eingehen wird er in mail vom
kompakter wird das ganze dann irgendwie
auf machen und wird dann sehen
k s von craft erhalten und hier noch mal
gras von kontrakt erhalten
und das kann man auf dem server ganz gut
anwenden weil das ganze ist auch server
tauglich und dann will ich sagen was das
ist man mit den ersten sachen machen
ganz kurzem hat und dann sehen wir uns
durch wiesel bild dem wirken gehe ich
richtig möchte und zwar kommt er noch
viel dazu so und jetzt habe ich das
ganze muss ein bisschen umgebaut also
wir sehen hier schon haben sich ein paar
dinge verändert und zwar haben wir hier
zum beispiel jetzt dieses werk bad ich
habe das amt des bergbaus ist einfach
was ganz cooles können vögel hinkommen
und sieht da drauf setzen wenn erst mal
mehr für gegeben würde in minecraft und
es ist einfach sondern auch seine
dekoration sattel mailbox habe ich ab
wohin schon erklärt wir haben jetzt hier
noch einen tab und zwar ist ein tab ein
wasserhahn weg als ihr recht auf machen
die mieter harry potter source andere
blog wird s&t user also wir müssen eine
wasserquelle da machen wo das ding
draufsteht falls sie das heißt jetzt
meine tochter man kann eine drei blöcke
breite wasserquelle machen das heißt
jetzt sicher in block hin und da also
jetzt nämlich wieder die erdung war das
ganze einfach wieder zu und jetzt können
wir richtig drauf machen jetzt wird ihr
wasser gespart und wir können es dann
mit einem eimer mitnehmen und dort eine
unendliche quelle ist ist darunter quasi
die ganze zeit wasser außer wenn wir das
zu schnell klicken dann kommt die
meldung init er hätte wortes hautnah
blabla weil die wasserquelle sich ja
dann auch wieder zusammenfließen mussten
das dauert ja mal ganz kleinen moment
also das ist der tipp wenn wir ihre
eigenen sehen wie schön es hat sich
einiges verändert und zwar haben wir
jetzt hier technologie drin wie
beispielsweise diese lampen oder
computer und drucker und hier haben wir
jetzt beispielsweise mal die küche drin
sein
wir fangen wir erstmal an hier links in
der ecke ist ein ganz normale lampe die
funktioniert mit redstone ich hab das
jetzt einfach gemacht indem ich da oben
der rats am fackel hingestellt habe ihr
könnt es auch machen indem ihr irgendwie
eine schnur dahin liegt und die lampe an
unter einem richtigen tisch park sondern
von aus
redstone blabla wenn wir können einfach
recht gebrauch machen und die lampe ist
an und aus das jetzt richtig licht macht
sehen wir quasi nur hier kurz an diesem
zaun der ein bisschen heller wird mehr
sehen wir daran nicht wir müssen wieder
alles ausstellen die ganzen lions ihr zu
machen habe ich aber gar nicht so bock
drauf
die machen einfach weiter im programm
und zwar mit dem computer und mit dem
print ab wir können ihn kommt wieder
ganz einfach an stellen dem rechtsweg
drücken wir machen das allerdings noch
nicht uns warum uns vorher noch so ein
paar die am männchen unseren preisen und
was wir uns auch noch holen würde ich
mal sagen ist mohammed denn wo haben wir
denn hier beispielsweise sind und jetzt
können wir ganz einfach mal richtig
drauf machen jetzt den wir nämlich schon
die preise das kleine erfahrungs flächen
kostet zum beispiel einreisen
seit ich lebe jetzt hier ein eiserner
antike auf buy und ich bekomme einen
erfahrungs fläschchen das gleiche können
wir auch machen indem wir zum beispiel
zwei eisen reinlegen klicken wir wieder
auf buy und auf bayern dann haben wir
das wieder und dann haben wir wieder
zwei erfahrung special gesagt ist halt
nur wir sind im creative mord und blabla
und dass manche wissen warum wir können
ja auch einfach jemanden legen uns um
zum beispiel ganz viele bilder kaufen
dann kommen die herausgelockt haben wir
ganz viele bilder dann kommen wir
bekommen unser diamanten zurück also es
ist das ganze nennt sich mein base also
ein bisschen von ebay ob mit dem design
und so soll ebay darstellen ist ganz
cool gemacht und mit dem print ist es
auch ganz kunden zwar können mich
einfach ein verzaubertes buch einlegen
passiert allerdings noch nicht nix
nämlich wir brauchen dafür die inc die
in cork brady in karts bridge und die
kann man da einfach einlegen und dann
können wir einen moment in wird gleich
irgendwann dieses buch
heraus kommen also weil es kopiert wird
das gleiche dauerte es da ich muss ganz
vertauschen es dauert nämlich in
momenten und zwar sehen wir das hier
diese cartridge geht ein bisschen runter
das ist quasi erfüllt patronen heißt das
ja übersetzt und das ist der stand wie
lange das ganze noch braucht um das
ganze irgendwie zu kopieren
also es dauert wirklich sehr lange bei
den normalen buch geht schneller
und ja wir können einfach mal ein
bisschen abwarten eventuell wird es
nachher fertig kopiert sein ich weiß ja
nicht kann man einfach mal abwarten und
wir gehen einfach weiter zur küche da
haben wir hier oben den fritzsche kann
man sachen reinlegen hier beispielsweise
wenn ich als eisenbahn nehmen kann ich
ihn nicht reinlegen sondern nicht an da
wirklich nur sachen darlegen wie als sie
nicht essen und so ich kann unten auf
den trip draufklicken und ich sehe hier
viele hier ist ein feld und da kommt
dann irgendwas raus park erst mal kurz
die sache nie weg die wollten mich nicht
und zwar indem ich da ganz kurz mal
wieder sachen aus meinem fritsch aus
meiner kabinett da oben raus und zwar
packe ich jetzt einfach mal ob es da
unten hier kommt nämlich dass viel rein
das sind cooling packs die ganzen
kräftigen rezepte findet ihr auf der
website also ihr wenn ihr euch gefragt
wie man sich das kräfte tim ganz und in
der beschreibung ist ein link zum motto
dann könnt ihr einfach mal drauf klicken
wir können jetzt beispielsweise giftige
kartoffeln reinlegen ich packte aber
nicht so viele rein und dann sehen wir
schon dass dieser felder ausgefüllt wird
und jetzt gleich sehen wir wir bekommen
eine normale kartoffeln raus
das läuft so ab also ich packe sie zum
beispiel verrottetes fleisch rein so
aber auch wieder nicht alles ich bin
schneller als dieser fall gefordert die
anzieht dann nur noch ein stück dran
dann haben wir hier zum beispiel ein
flash und dieses fleisch ist jetzt
einfach ein ganz normaler hinzugefügt
das fleisch also man kann das verrottete
fleisch normales leisten fleisch machen
aus
den pausen des kartoffeln kann man
normale potatoes machen aus einem eimer
lava kann man obsidian rausbekommen aus
leimholz kann man was machen ganz ganz
viele sachen das findet ihr auch alles
in der website
und dann kann ich beispielsweise das
fleisch herein tun in den ofen der auch
hinzugefügt wurde da ist auch so ein up
zucht dinge einfach nur zur dekoration
und jetzt verwandelt sich das ganze
gleich in gebratenes fleisch in der zeit
praktisch mal einfach mal in sachen hier
weg jetzt sehen wir gleich ist es zu
gebratenem fleisch auch wenn wir hier
mal drauf klicken
sehen wir hier ist fleisch und guckt
flash hinzugefügt worden
und das ist jetzt jeden moment fällig in
der zwischenzeit das einfach eine ganz
normale druckplatte die ich hingelegt
haben das sind diese tische über die
schon geredet hat das einfach comeback
um das ganze bisschen schöner zu machen
kabinett hatten wir auch schon in der
zwischenzeit ist auch ein stück fleisch
fertig sodann kann mir das einfach
gucken gucken kochen so hier haben wir
jetzt ein stereo box da kann man sich
drauf machen mit der musik gespielt die
maske es mal wieder weg die musik weckt
das braucht man nämlich nicht
hier ist jetzt ein feueralarm und dieser
feueralarm ist sehr sehr brauchbar sag
ich mal wenn ich jetzt nämlich zum
beispiel mal einfach so ein feuerzeug
nehmen würde und das machen würde
heute scheint teil piept das kann ein
bisschen irritierend allerdings was cool
ist wenn das ganze team ist dass wir
einfach mal von außen da rangehen können
so dass pete natürlich weiterhin
ich glaube ich weiß mehr wo ich den
angebracht habe ich glaube hier
aber nicht im moment wo war da ist wo
war das häufchen testing angebracht oder
den da oben angebracht oder hier
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht mehr genau
welchen angebracht hat jedenfalls könnt
ihr am block dahinter dieser feier
melder jetzt ruckelte total
er sendet ein signal aus ich zeige es
jetzt einmal ganz kurz hier vorne damit
jetzt hier sehen könnt ich stelle hier
jetzt beispielsweise mal so den vatikan
den feuermelder hin zündeten feuer an
das teil realisiert ist und jetzt sendet
der da oben nämlich ein redstone signal
aus was ihr irgendwie was hat überhaupt
nicht funktioniert
ich weiß ich weiß nicht woran es liegt
dass das ganze gar nicht funktioniert
aber jedenfalls sendet er einen redstone
signal aus und dieses rats tonsignal
könnt ihr dann beispielsweise an
irgendeinen testen dran bauen der dann
irgendwie wasser rein schüttelt und das
teure wohnung wieder gelöscht also
eigentlich sollte es ganz funktionieren
vielleicht packt auch einfach nur um sex
texture pack weil die sachen meistens
einfach hinzugefügt wurden dieser feier
am halt nicht wir sehen hier
beispielsweise die texturen wurden
zwecks angepasst und so sieht ganz cool
aus einem nur beim feiern halt nicht
vielleicht liegt's daran ich bin mir
aber nicht sicher
dann haben wir hier den binnen- und zwar
nehme ich mir jetzt einfach mal ein paar
blöcke zusammen und kann mit ihnen bin
einfach so sachen reinpacken empty
klicken und dann ist dieser müller immer
quasi sachen auf das ist quasi genauso
wie wenn wir in bulawa hinstellen und
den ölstand das ist dieser das bin quasi
und da haben wir noch einen fernseher
haben couch hingestellt keine es richtig
drauf machen dann läuft hier etwas die
luft neuen cat und dann ist der fenster
kaputt und dann konstatierten vorne
machen also sind die einzigen drei
sender aber hey wir haben einen
fernseher darüber habe ich ja schon mal
in den kräftigen ideen geredet ist ganz
cool war und den gibt es in der firma j
und dann haben wir hier auch eine
türklingel die auch hinzugefügt wurde
und das sind jetzt erstmal so die sachen
so küche wohnzimmer mäßig technologie
die ich euch zeigen wollte und stammt
würde ich sagen richtig das ganze jetzt
um und dann sehen wir uns sofort wieder
mit der letzten sache und zwar dem
badezimmer so freunde ich habe jetzt
hier ein paar sachen wieder drin
verändert das könnte wahrscheinlich
wieder sehen und zwar wurden jetzt dinge
hinzugefügt wie beispielsweise duschen
badewannen waschbecken beendet schon
wieder und zwar kabinett also wo man
sachen einpacken kann und so eine
toilette und einen mülleimer die
funktions müllers habe ich ja schon
erklärt und sagen und löschen etc
das gleiche geht mit der toilette auch
dazu komme ich aber am ende war die
toilette des kults ist also ich würde
sagen wir machen erstmal die duschen
zwar kann man ganz einfach rein laufen
und über dem jetzt an der duschkopf und
der hat uns dann ab dieter relativ cola
für den stein da hinten macht es mal
wieder aus und gleich was die duschen
bringt und zwar wenn ihr zum beispiel in
vergiftungs effekt hat macht er den weg
oder wenn ihr auch schnelligkeit oder
sorg macht er den weg also der spielt
euch ab wie milch quasi wie wenn ihr
milch trinkt und wenn ihr zum beispiel
verfärbte wenn ihre fahrpläne wenn ihr
wie heißt das gefärbte gefärbte nicht
verfärbt wenn ihr gefärbt leder rüstung
an habt dann macht sie die ungefähr die
dusche dahin ist weder jeopardy handy so
das ist die dusche dann können wir das
bad machen und können uns ein bad nehmen
das geht aber nur da steht ihr nie die
harry potter stars andere blog barth hat
ist on to fill it also wir haben hier
die badewanne das heißt wir gehen hier
ist der blog auf den die bande steht ihm
noch ein runter müssen hier quasi eine
wasserquelle machen das heißt sie macht
wieder so eine dreiteilige wasser
quelle da ein da ich stelle einfach mal
über wasser hin ezb wird es so dann
mache ich das ganze wieder zu halogen
und jetzt können wir hier vertraut
machen
kurz partner geht der wasser rein wieder
kutschfahrten es ganz schnell mache ist
das gleich über dem tab nicht außen
angebracht habe dass das ganze wieder
nachholen muss wir können es aber da
steht alternativ alternativ rock on the
water backe titel nennt heute findet
also wir können hier beispielsweise auch
einfach wasser einmal neben der wird
jetzt bei mir zum beispiel nicht lehrer
weil ich im creative not been und
irgendwann ist das bad an voll und dann
kann ich damit nichts machen aber es
sieht einfach cool aus und des bartes
von und es ist einfach wieder seine
wassereinlagerung also wir können mit
dem leeren einmal darauf hin und ins
wasser da rausnehmen
genau das gleiche ist hier mit diesem
teil und zwar steht auch hinter hayward
ist horst bla bla bla bla
wir können uns also wieder hier runter
bauen und machen da wieder eine
wasserquelle hin benutzen wir einfach
das eine ende von dieser anderen
wasserquelle von dem badezimmer schon
das ganze kann man relativ cool
verbinden und können direkt drauf machen
dann ist da wasser drin und dann ist es
wieder so eine wasserquelle also wir
können uns da wasser raus nehmen
die walt kabinett ist einfach wir können
die sachen reinpacken wie beispielsweise
ich packte man birkenholz breit reingeht
allerdings nicht was er einmal zeit
reagiert auch nicht das einzige was ich
dort rein füllen kann ist sind passions
weil das ganze pushen das soll so ein
bisschen so medizin darstellen ein
kleiner kapitän schrenk in seiner
apotheke schränkchen und dann nämlich
apotheker schränken die seen noch mal
anders aus welche rolle egal jedenfalls
soll es sein kann es medizin teil
darstellen wo sozialen passiert so was
drinsteht dass das nicht gibt hat den
weg der sich einfach gedacht kann man da
halt nur porsches reinstellen also seine
passion lagerung
kommen wir zur toilette und zwar können
uns darauf setzen und wir sehen schon
die geilste funktion wir können f
drücken
und können ganz viel spaß auf diesem klo
haben also wir können wirklich kurzes
nicken und wir gehen quasi wieder runter
das sei auch gerade ein bisschen komisch
aussah sich das mal an nicht aufs nickel
so kurz mal im buch einstecken
und dann können wir hier auch obst jetzt
habe ich das ganze blut nur so wenn du
da hätte ich schon dass abgeräumt schiff
drücken und wir können dann
beispielsweise jetzt auch und lenker mit
direkten wir können eine wall kabinett
orange meisten wirken holzbretter
unterstützer sind wassereimer dann mache
ich das ganze wieder ich nicke mich und
es hat die gleiche funktion wie ein
mülleimer also die sachen werden quasi
abgezogen das würde ich sag jetzt hier
ist cape das würde ich sagen was mit
dieser modifikation sonst wurde ich habe
glaube ich alle dinge gezeigt wenn ich
irgendetwas vergessen habe was ich
eventuell nicht liegt doch ich hab doch
ich habe alles gezeigt ich glaub ich hab
alles gezeigt wenn ich irgendwas
vergessen habe zu erwähnen dann könnt
ihr das endlich auf der website
nachlesen oder mir die kommentare
schreiben
wann etwas längere mod review der ab
wenn das video wahrscheinlich wird
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht vor 8 uhr
heute online gewesen sein am 19
das liegt ganz einfach daran weil ich so
ein scheiß internet habe und dann würde
ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat und
je mehr von solchen klotz wollen die
wirklich also die letzte mal bei die
selfdott die einfach nur einem zugefügt
hat mit dem ein bisschen spaß haben kann
und es fügt jetzt so viele sachen hinzu
und alles mögliche also wenn ihr mehr
davon wollte zeigt es mir mit einem
daumen nach oben und schreibt eventuell
mods in die kommentare und wir sehen uns
in der nächsten folge wieder morgen